If nothing can be faster than the speed of
light, why don’t we make the speed of light
faster?
Hey there speedsters, Julian here for DNews.
Unless you’re a certain comic book character
who keeps messing up the timeline -- Barry
-- you can’t go faster than the speed of
light.
It’s the top, the be all end all of speed,
and nothing can go faster than it, including
itself, and it’s always been that way, period.
End of story.
OR IS IT???
That’s what theoretical physicists at the
Imperial College of London are trying to figure
out.
Decades ago, they proposed that the speed
of light may have been faster in the early
days of the universe.
They weren’t able to test their prediction
because instruments weren’t sensitive enough
to precisely measure the cosmic microwave
background radiation, a.k.a. the light leftover
from the Big Bang.
Now you may be wondering, why would they even
think the speed of light might have been different
at any point?
Well, all across the universe, the cosmic
background radiation seems to be about the
same temperature no matter where you look,
and this is puzzling.
For that to be true, photons across the universe
must have interacted and settled into an equilibrium,
but given the size of the universe and the
speed of light, that’s just not possible.
The most commonly accepted way to get around
this so called “Horizon problem” is known
as the Inflation Theory.
This idea states that when the universe was
just 10-35 seconds old --so a decimal point
with 34 zeroes and then a 1 seconds--, it
expanded by a factor of 1026 --which is an
insanely bigly number-- in a tiny fraction
of a second, before chilling out and expanding
at the much less ludicrous speed we see today.
That means before the universe stretched out
at the speed we see today: the photons could
have been in equilibrium.
The Inflation Theory is so popular because
it solves the Horizon Problem along with other
issues the Big Bang Theory presents.
But there's another way around this problem…
what if the speed of light isn't constant?
Why not have light just... move faster?
That’s what these scientists are trying
to figure out, and it would challenge a huge
precedent.
See one of Einstein's biggest breakthroughs
came with the discovery that light is always
traveling at a certain speed, specifically
299,792,458 m/s.
I don’t care who you are, where you’re
from, what you did, as long as you measure
light, that’ll be the speed.
If you’re driving at 100 miles an hour and
turn on your headlights, the photons coming
out of them don’t go 100 miles an hour faster.
Einstein realized if the speed of light is
constant, then space and time could be flexible
parts of the equation and the theory of Special
Relativity was born.
And this constant speed thing seems to hold
up no matter what we do.
Some of you may have seen stories about scientists
slowing down light.
But they're not.
not really.
When light goes through a medium like water
or a pane of glass -- which is probably how
you've seen light "slowed down" the photons
themselves aren’t traveling more slowly,
they’re just bouncing off the atoms and
taking a less direct path.
It’s why when they leave the medium light
travels quickly again, instead of staying
at its slower speed.
This illustrates why people usually specify
that there’s nothing faster than the speed
of light in a vacuum.
So right now, the speed of light seems pretty
darn fixed.
But so does the rate the universe is expanding.
13.8 billion years ago, when the universe
was brand new and the rules were like the
wild west of physics, maybe one of those things
wasn’t so steady.
When our instruments are good enough we’ll
test this new idea and if it’s wrong, we’ll
stick with cosmic inflation.
If it’s accurate, well, we’re going to
have a lot of rethinking to do.
If cosmic inflation theory IS true, then there
could be parallel universes.
To learn how and see me IN TRIPLICATE, check
out this awesome 360 video we made on the
topic.
So which makes more sense to you, insane inflation
or an upped speed of light?
You can let us know in the comments, subscribe
for more and we'll see you next time on DNews.